My name is Gonzalo
Tazu, and today
I will be
talking about the
neuroanatomy of
olfaction and taste.
We'll describe the
cellular organization of
the human olfactory
and gustatory systems.
We'll explain how
afferent, afferent,
afferent, efferent
in both senses
contribute to the
communication between
the sensory epithelia
and the brain.
We'll explain a
little bit about the
specific brain related
to the complexity
of smell and taste
sensation. We'll
compare and contrast
both systems and we'll
also talk about
specific disease states.
Olfaction. So this is one
of the chemical senses
and um and it's
there's importance and
clinical importance
for this for example uh
parkinson patients
show olfactory deficit
for example four years
before showing any
motor symptoms so
it's important for us
to understand the
physiology of olfaction
So the human olfaction,
briefly, we have
molecules in the air,
and these molecules
enter in contact with
olfactory epithelium,
where they are sensory
neurons, and that
information is transmitted
into the olfactory
bulb and from the
olfactory bulb into
the rest of the brain.
There are two routes
for olfaction. One
is the one that you
probably are thinking
about, where the
odors enter through the
nose, and we call the
ortonasal, where the
odors enter into the
nasal cavity and make
contact. However,
it's also for humans,
it's very important,
the retronasal, where
the food that we
have ingested from the
mouth, the volatile
molecules enter into
the nasal cavity and
also make contact.
And this retronasal is
very important for the
sensation of flavor,
which is the
combination of taste and
olfaction produced by
the food that we eat.
So what happens in the
olfactory epithelium
is we have in here
on the lower part,
we can see the epithelium
where the other
molecules are going
to make contact. there
they are going to
we're going to find
the olfactory receptive
cells we have this
cilia where the
olfactory receptors are
actually located so
we are going to have
some sensation here
so there is also going
to be the Bowman gland
that's going to be
producing this mucus
which is very important
for the normal
function of olfaction
and there also to be
these basal cells so
the olfactory cells
are these first order
bipolar neurons also
known as olfactory
neurosensory cells or
primary olfactory neurons
they have dendrites
with specialized cilia
these neurons are
short-lived they only
live for seven days
and so processes
that affect cell
division will also affect
olfaction in
particular chemotherapy
now here we have also
basal cells which
are stem cells that
are going to give
rise to the olfactory
receptor cells
so the olfactory
receptor cells require
the support of other
cells so there are the
the sustentacular
cells, which have
microbillus and secretory
glandulans. They also
produce mucus, and
they provide structural
stability to the
olfactory epithelium.
They are also the
cells that are
associated with the
Bowman glands here,
and they secrete
the mucus fluid
containing
glycoprotein. So,
the importance of
these sustentacular
cells have been
emphasized in later years.
As it turns out, the
sustentacular cells
express the ACE2
receptor, which actually
is used by the COVID
-19 virus to enter
into the epithelium.
So, as it turns out,
the olfactory receptor
cells do not express
this receptor, so the
virus is entering into
the body through the
sustentacular cells.
So, what are
olfactory receptors?
How does the
chemical sense,
chemical input, turn
into electrical activity?
So the olfactory
receptor proteins
are G protein
copper receptors,
and they bind an
array of odorants.
We humans have
only 300 olfactory
receptor genes. Compared
to other species,
for example mice
that depend much
more on olfaction,
they have a higher
number of olfactory
receptor G1200.
When a molecule binds to
these olfactory
receptors,
a receptor other
incompletes form,
which activates
the G protein.
This triggers a cascade
of second messengers
that causes opening
of cation channels of
sodium, potassium, and
calcium that they are
going to enter into
the cell, the calcium
influx causes the
opening of these calcium
-gated chloride channels.
Opening the chloride
channels causes
depolarization of an olfactory
receptor neuron, and
it's going to amplify
the receptor potential.
This potential
spreads to the trigger
zone of the receptor
neuron and initiates
the action potential. So
the olfactory
nerve is the
cranial nerve number one.
So the unmelinated
actions of the olfactory
cells gather into
about 20 bundles. So
these that are going to
be on one side on the
olfactory epithelium
separated by a bone
from the olfactory
bulb. They have to
traverse through this
bone, which is in the
clippiform plane in the
ethmoid bone. So these
fibers have to cross
through the bone to
reach the olfactory
bulb and they are going
to make synapses
creating structures in
the olfactory bulb
called the glomerulus.
So here we have
another diagram where
we can see this
with more clarity.
So here we have the
nasal cavity and here
in this part you
can see the ethmoid
bone and the cribiform
plate where the
bundles of nerve fibers
are going to cross
here's another detail
what this is of
the anterior fossa and
the cribiform plate
where we can see
the little holes on
one side is the
olfactory epithelium and
on the other side is
the olfactory bulb
so it is actually
quite interesting what
happens in the olfactory
bulb so as we said we
have 300 different
olfactory receptor genes
each of the olfactory
receptor neurons
express only one of
these genes and what is
interesting is that
they are distributed all
over the olfactory
epithelium However, when
they cross into the
olfactory bulb, all the
axons that are coming
from neurons that
express the same olfactory
receptor are going
to converge into one
single structure, which
is called the olfactory
bulb, the olfactory
glomerulus. So we are
going to have glomerulus
are going to have
axons from receptor
neurons that express a
single receptor gene.
How is the odor
produced by an object
in the environment
encoded? So it is not
the case that each
olfactory receptor
is going to respond
to a single object.
but each receptor
bind to, can bind to
multiple objects, and
it's going to be actually
which combination of
olfactory receptors
that is activated
that's going to
determine the identity
of another. For example,
here in this graph
we have some e that
represent the olfactory
bulb and then you
can see here some
cartoon of the glomerular
at these little
circles and the active
in the bulb bread
produces this combination
of receptors that are
being activated we
can see that and then
wine will have for
example a different
pattern so then we'll
if we see this pattern
of glomerular being
activated then we'll
know that it's wine
and so on and this
information is going
to be transported to
the olfactory cortex.
So this is an
example where we can
use optical techniques
to image the
activity in the
olfactory bulb. This
is from a recent
paper from my
laboratory where we
image the responses
in the olfactory bulb to
a chemical
ethyl butyrate.
so here you can see
that there's air
so there's no
activity and then you
can see these dark
spots appearing this
corresponds to
activated glomeruli
and the combination
of this glomeruli
determines the identity
of the other so
here for example we
can see different maps
that are produced by
different chemicals.
So, which combination
of olfactory
glomeruli is produced
by an odor is going
to determine the
identity of the odor, and
the brain has to
decode that activity.
So, you talk about
the glomeruli.
Now, in the olfactory
bulb, that information
has to reach the rest
of the brain so we
have the glomeruli are
conducted by the dendrites
of the mitral and
the tufted cells and
these cells constitute
the output of the
olfactory bulb and
transmit the
olfactory information
to other parts of
the brain so this
activity is actually
regulated there are
interneurons, that is
neurons that release the
inhibitory neurotransmitter
GABA in the olfactory
bulb. These are the
granule cells and the
periglomerular cells.
These cells receive
feedback input from
other brain areas for all
these centrifugal
fibers. Also they receive
input from the
raffin nucleus and
from the nucleus
structure coriolis.
So these inputs are
going to modulate
these internators,
which in turn will
modulate the output
of the olfactory bulb.
So the olfactory
tracts are the fiber
tracts that carry the
information from the
olfactory bulb to other
parts of the brain.
Again, they are formed
by the axon of the
mitral and the tufted
cells, so these
olfactory tracts
expand at the olfactory
trigo, which is this
anatomical structure.
So there is a lateral
and a medial strial.
The lateral tract
is the main output
of the olfactory ball,
and it's going to
project to the primary
olfactory cortex.
The medial olfactory
stria are going to cross
to the other side of
the brain and make
contact to another
structure called the
anterior olfactory
nucleus so the anterior
olfactory nucleus
receives input from one
glomerulus which receives
input from one nostril
and it's going to
receive the input from
the other nostril so
there's going to be a
comparison from both
nostrils and that can
be used it's uh it has
been speculated that
it might have to do
for other localization
So here, this you
will see more clearly
when you're in the
anatomy lab. So we have
the olfactory bulb,
and then there's the
olfactory tract. And
the olfactory tract
is going to connect
to the olfactory
tubercle, which is
part of this olfactory
cortex. This is also
going to connect to the
periphone cortex, which
is the main recipient
of the output of
the olfactory bulb.
and other parts that
receive olfactory
input include the
periamidaloid cortex
as well as the para
-hippocampal gyrus
which is part of
the entorhinal cord
so there is also an
olfactor as we mentioned
before there is also
the uh um the anterior
olfactory nucleus
which connects the two
olfactory bulbs and
there is the piriform
cortex which is the
main recipient of the
lateral olfactory
tract the piriform
cortex is part of
the limbic system
and connects to
the entorhinal
cortex to the
dorsal entorhinal
area as well as
to the amygdala
something that is
worth mentioning is
that olfaction is
different from under
sensory modalities
in that there does
not exist an olfactory
thalamus however
people uh the piriform
cortex projects
this primary piriform
cortex the primary
olfactory cortex projects
to the mediodorsal
thalamic nucleus and
people consider that
there and in the
mediodorsal thalamic
nucleus you are going
to find neurons that
respond to others
and these mediodorsal
thalamic nucleus sends
projections to the
insular cortex as
we'll see later this is
where gustatory inputs
also go so here we
have an integration
of smell and taste
which is going to
produce the sensation of
flavor it also
projects to the orbit
orbitofrontal cortex
So it's going to relate
to the process of
reward and motivation.
Interestingly, we saw
that there is this
beautiful structure
in the olfactory
bulb called the
glomeruli, where the axons
of the olfactory
receptor neuron that
express the same gene
converge. However,
this structure disappears
in the piriform
cortex. Here you are
seeing in vivo imaging
in the piriform
cortex, and here in red
represents the activation
of the neurons that
are activated by an
individual odor. So,
you would have expected
that the structure
of glomeruli will be
maintained in the piriform
cortex. However, that
structure is lost,
and others are
represented by distributed
populations of neurons
in the piriform
cortex. The exact reason
of that is unknown.
So, there are
olfactory disorders.
and olfactory disorders
can be quantitative
so here for example
we have sensitivity
and a normosmic person
is a person that has
normal self sensation
people that have
decreased smell sensation
are described as
hyposmic and an anosmic
is a person that has
a complete absence
of smell sensation so
anosmia affects 3
.2 percent of u.s
adults who are aged
more than 40 years so
that's a population
of 3.4 million
people so the uh anosmia
is a large problem
that affects a large
number of people
and the number of
people that are
affected by anosmia
increases with age
So between 14
and 22 percent of
people over 60 and
older are anosmic.
The most common causes
are synonasal diseases,
post-infectious
disorders, and post
-traumatic disorders.
So we'll talk about
that a little bit
more in more detail.
And other etiologies,
congenital idiopathic
toxic disorders or
disorders caused by
neurodegenerative
disease are less common.
So besides the
quantitative
olfactory disorder,
there are also
qualitative
olfactory disorders.
So these are divided
in two types. One is
the parosmia, when
the stimulus is real
but elicits a false
sensation. For example,
baby powder, a very
nice and pleasant
smell, is going to
smell like, for these
people with parosmias,
as burned paper.
And very common,
actually, is that people,
for some reason,
coffee is one of
these stimulus that
has caused trouble in
parosmias, if
people describe, for
example, that coffee
smells like gasoline.
not surprisingly
the vast majority of
patients describe these
parosmic experiences as
unpleasant it's even
more unpleasant than
being anosmic and
interestingly these
parosmias are associated
with initially with a
loss of olfactory
function so somebody
starts with an anosmia
and a hyposmia and later
on is going to develop
these parosmias.
Interestingly, and
something that you
will see in your
clinical practice,
is that the parosmia,
there's an increase
in the number
of parosmias induced
after the COVID
-19 infection induced
anosmia, which
affects 7.1% of
these patients.
Another word
that is used to
describe the parosmia
is gacostmia,
But in that case,
the term is used
when the perceived
smell is foul.
So, besides
this parosmia,
there are phantosmia,
when there
is no actual
physical smell.
However, there is a
random sensation of a
smell in the absence of
stimulus. The parosmias
are not associated
with a loss of falstery
function. And as
we'll see later on,
they can be produced,
for example, by epileptic
seizure in the uncus,
that is the part
close where the pitiform
cortex is located.
So there are other
syndromes that
are characterized
by a smell being
affected and are
very characteristic.
One of them is the
Kalman syndrome,
which is a hypogonadotropic
hypogonadism,
so there's a lack of
pituitary hormones,
LH and FSH, which
results in the late
puberty, and these
people also have anosmia.
Another clinic syndrome
that also can be
presented with
hyposmia is the Foster
-Kennedy syndrome where
there is a meningioma
of the olfactory
groove which compresses
the olfactory tract
and the optic nerve.
It results in
ipsilateral anosmia
and the optic
nerve atrophy and
possibly contralateral
papillus.
So there is, as we
age, our sense of male
is going to deteriorate
with normal aging.
However,
there's also neurodegenerative
diseases like
Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's disease, where
there is an accelerated
loss of olfaction.
an important cause
of anosmia could be
trauma so as we saw the
fibers from the olfactory
the nerves from the
olfactory epithelium
have to cross this
cribiform plate to
reach the olfactory bulb
so if there is trauma
to the head then there
could be a fracture
of the floor of the
anterior cranial
fossa in this case the
crib is going to be
affected so these uh
fibers these nerves are
going to be disturbed
number one and it
will result in an osmia
and csf rhenorrhea
and another cause of of
that another olfactory
dysfunction could
be this unzeny fits
where an individual
is going to repair
before getting an
epileptic seizure is going
to report auras of foul
smelling odors just
before the seizure
onset the pitiform area
is very susceptible
to generate seizures
and partial complex
epilepsy can generate
it can be originated
in this medial
temporal focus in
the ancus, and then
that will produce
these auras of smells
preceding the onset
of the seizure.
Allergia renatis can
also be caused by
lateral liposmia.
Interestingly, when people
have looked at biopsies
of the olfactory
mucosa, you can see
that the sensory
epithelial cells are
still present, but
their cilia are all
deformed and shortened
and are buried under
other mucosal cells.
Besides is more
peripheral forms of causes
of olfactory losses
this interestingly in
the Korsakov psychosis
there is also a
hypostomia so what happens
is that in Korsakov
psychosis there is damage
to the diencephalon
right like the
mammillary bodies but
also into the medial
talamic nucleus So, as
you remember, people
with alcohol use
disorder can have a
deficiency in vitamin B1,
and there's going to
be problems with memory
and co-fabulation.
But also, anosmia
might be present, and
it's thought to be caused
by the degeneration
of the neurons in
the higher-order olfactory
systems, including
the mediodorsal
nucleus of the talibus.
So this is actually
quite interesting
because it's
a more central
cause for an
olfactory dysfunction.
So let's review the
olfactory pathway.
So the odorants in
the environment travel
via orto and retronasal
and activate the
olfactory receptors.
These olfactory receptors
and neurons are in the
mucosa, and the fibers
cross through the
cribiform plane into the
olfactory bulb. There,
the olfactory bulb,
we find the mitral and
the tufted cells, the
two main output cells
of the olfactory bulb.
These olfactory bulb
cells then project to
other areas, including
the piriform cortex,
the anterior
olfactory nucleus,
the amygdala, and the
entorhinal cortex. So,
now let's talk
about taste.
So, taste refers
to the activation
by chemicals of
the receptors
in our mouth,
in the tongue.
So, there are 5 by 6
sensations of taste,
sweet, bitter, salty,
sour, and umami.
uh you are probably
you are familiar
you're probably
familiar familiar with
the first four
umami is a japanese
word for the pleasant
savory taste so
you can imagine
that in uh soy sauce
cheese and uh ripped
tomatoes and it's
produced by glutamate
and nucleotides
that are going to cause
this umami
taste sensation.
So the sensation of
taste is going to
be located in the
taste buds, which are
the sensory organs
of the taste system.
So the taste buds,
which are these groups
of sensory neurons,
you can see that the
taste cells look kind
of similar to the
olfactor receptor
neurons they have the
micro billy and there's
this aperture where
you can the chemicals
are going to come
in and these cells are
also in general these
sensory neurons that
are exposed to all
these chemical sensors
have short lives
same here and there's
also basal cells
so there's going to
be renewal of these
cell of the tail cells.
So these tail cells
are located on the
papillae, which are
the protrusions on the
surface of the tongue,
you can see them, and
they are different,
they have different
forms, they are filiform,
fungiform, foliate,
and syncunvalate
papillae. The filiform
and the fungiform
papillae are scattered
through the surface of
the anterior two-thirds
of the tongue, especially
along the lateral
margins so we'll
talk about the what
chemicals or what aspects
of the chemical work
is going to be reported
by the different
and these receptors.
So salt is actually
going to be reporting
the content of sodium
in food through
the ameliorate
-sensitive sodium
channels. So the
gastrointestinal receptor
neurons are going
to have channels
that are going to let
sodium in. And that
way we are going
to be able to tell
if the content of
salt in our food the
polarization of the
membrane so sodium goes
in the membrane depolarizes
and opens voltage
activated calcium
channels to amplify
this activation and
this calcium triggers
the release of synaptic
vesicles and are
going to activate
degustatory afferent axis.
For SAUR,
so this is going to be
our body's pH sensor,
our TONGS pH sensor.
They are going to
detect the protons
and it's mediated by
the closure of voltage
-dependent potassium
channels. The
polarization of the
membrane again opens
voltage activity in
calcium channels and
the calcium again
triggered the release
of inactive vesicles
activating gustatory
afferent access
so now uh so so far
the two sensations uh
sour and salty were
were directly activated
channels now the
sweet and bitter are
actually slightly
different they are going
to be using g-protein
copper receptors.
Sweet taste is
mediated by activation
of the g-proteins
and adenylate
cyclase which is
going to increase the
levels of cyclic
adenosine monophosphate
producing membrane
depolarization.
Bitter substances are
going to activate a
g-protein that activates
phospholipase C and
generate ip3 producing
calcium release
from internal stores
so because we are using
g protein capital
receptors there's going to
be as you are aware an
amplification of the
signal and that
actually starts to make
sense if we think that
we want to be able to
detect very low levels
of bitter substances
in the natural world
bitter substances is a
warning from plants
telling us that they
are toxic so we want to
be able to detect that
and that's why we have
this very sensitive
system using g protein
coupled this receptor
to detect bitterness
we have over 30
different bitter
receptors animals that are
herbivores have even more
because they have they
are eating this all
these plants and plants
are telling us don't
eat us we are toxic
how how is taste
transmitted to the to the
central nervous
system so there's
innervation through
clinal nerve number seven
nine and ten taste buds
on the anterior two
-thirds of the tongue
are innervated by
the facial nerve clinal
nerve number seven
now the taste buds
on the posterior one
-third of the tongue
are innervated by the
glossopharyngeal nerve
clinal nerve number
nine And the taste
buds on the epiglottis
and pharyngeal walls
are innervated by
the Bagels nerve,
cranial nerve number 10.
All this gastratory
information is
going to converge
in the rostral valve
of the nucleus
of the solitary
tract in the dorsal
medulla, which is
here, close to the
fore ventricle.
So, remember that
in olfaction, there
is no olfactory thalamus
properly, however,
in gas station
there is a gastatory
thalamus. So as we
mentioned before,
we have the nucleus,
the gastatory part
in the nucleus of
the solitary tract.
these fibers close
to the fore ventricle
is going to ascend
through the solitary
thalamic tract and
is going to converge
to the posterior
medial nucleus
of the thalamus to
the ventral posterior
medial nucleus
of the thalamus
the bpm and the bpm
is the gastratory
thalamus the
gastatory thalamus is
going to send projections
to the primary
gastatory cortex
which is located in
the insula so the
insula is going is
where the gastatory
cortex is located
so the solitary tract
nucleus cells respond
broadly here to a wide
variety of different
tasting substances
whereas the gastric
cortex responses are much
more narrow here right
you can see that this
cell in the solitary
tract nucleus responds
to multiple substances
whereas the gastric
cortex this example
cell is only responding
to glucose so when
the gastric system is
affected we got that
adjusia and there are
multiple conditions
that could affect that
heavy smoking is one
of them so people have
actually made sure
that indeed smokers have
higher thresholds to
detect salt acid sucrose
or kinene um given
the location of the
innervation in the
anterior two-thirds of
the tongue by by facial
nerve in case of both
palsy there's also
going to be a lot of
gestation on that part.
And chemoradiotherapy
in the
head and neck,
for example,
can affect the
cranial nerves that
transmit gestatory
information.
So the olfactory
nerve, cranial
nerve 1, consists
of sensory neurons
that synapse in
the olfactory bone.
Cranial nerve number 1
carries only one single
modality, is a special
visceral average.
There is no incoming
precortical relay
of olfactory information
in the thalamus.
Then the olfactory
information
travels via the
mediodorsal nucleus
of the thalamus
to the insula
followed by the
orbitofrontal cortex.
Neurodegenerative
diseases such as
Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's disease
are often accompanied
by hyposmia
and remember that
each taste bad
harbors all five
varieties of non
-neuronal sensory
cells that are
connected to canal
nerve 7, 9, or 10.
So here we have some
practice questions.
Neurodegeneration as
seen in Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's
disease often
causes a noticeable
decline in odor
sensitivity. This
phenomenon is best
described as anosmia,
kakosmia, hyposmia,
parosmia, or phantosmia.
As this is just
a decline in
odor sensitivity
and not a complete
absence of odor
sensitivity,
this is an hyposmia.
Question number
2. A 15-year-old
girl with a family
history of Benin
meningiomas
presents with left
-sided absence of
smell sensation
and contralateral
papilledema. She
points out that her
symptoms worsen over
time. Her most
likely diagnosis is
cacostomia and senate
epileptic seizure,
gripe from
plane fracture,
early onset Parkinson's
disease, Foster
-Kennedy syndrome,
or Kalman syndrome.
Given that she has
that combination
of smell and
a papilledema
probably caused
by a meningioma
compressing the
optic nerve and
affecting the
olfactory tract.
Question number three.
A 15-year-old girl
who has been unable to
smell any odors since
Bert presents to her
pediatrician with a
complaint that she is
not developing any secondary
*** characteristics
which would have been
otherwise expected
for her age. Her
diagnosis is consistent
with congenital compression
of the olfactory
groove, early onset
Alzheimer's disease,
Foster-Kennedy syndrome,
Kalman syndrome,
and synod
epilepsy. Given the
absence or delay
of puberty and
the anosmia this
is a clear case
so this is something
that is relatively not
recent now it's about
the tropisms of of the
SARS-CoV-2 the virus
that caused COVID-19
so this was a study
done in cadavers where
people were looking for
uh rna copies of the
virus and interestingly
it was found mostly
in the olfactory mucosa
so that would explain
the i know the anosmia
or hyposmia produced
by kobe 19 by kobe
19 but also it also
found in the middle
of long gata so here
remember that's where
the place where we have
the nucleus of the
solitary tract where
gastrointestinal information
is being received.
So the tropism of
this SARS-CoV-2, so
which parts of the
brain are affected,
might explain
how the chemical
cancers are affected
in COVID-19.
And thank you very much
for your attention.